is house minority whip steve scalise is
with me sarah good day to you
here's the number more than 10 percent
of the traveling texas dems have tested
positive
what do you make of this well bill good
to be with you
and you know again the hypocrisy when
you know any time that there was anybody
on the republican side that tested
positive
they would automatically call it a super
spreader event the the mainstream media
would be running with it for days and
they would constantly be trying to blame
president trump for
for everybody who got coveted and then
here you have this event where they're
literally fleeing texas from doing their
jobs
uh to have voter integrity by the way
this lie that
uh that this bill is taking away
anybody's right it just ensures that
everybody who's legally eligible to vote
can vote but people who aren't legally
eligible can't vote
every state should want that these these
people were fleeing from trying to do
that
and then they spread covet here in
washington d.c
and uh you know and so ultimately i
think it just shows that the democrats
live under this double standard
they want you to live by a different set
of rules for them the rules shouldn't
apply to them
and the mainstream media just looks the
other way but i think people are seeing
this for what it is
okay a couple of things here you got you
are the antibodies right that's my
understanding
and you also were just vaccinated a few
days ago on sunday
um why would you wait so long for that
yeah months ago i had tested for the
antibodies
you know and so i would imagine maybe a
year ago early off i might have gotten
coveted but
uh didn't really have any symptoms but
had the antibodies but ultimately with
this new delta variant you're seeing
i've toured a lot of hospitals in the
last
few weeks and you're seeing the cases go
up it's not
to the alarming level that we saw last
year by any stretch we shouldn't be
uh you know talking about closing down
the economy where some people are trying
to do that some people talking about
closing things down again that's not
where we are but you do see about 95 to
98 percent of
people in the hospital for covet or
people that aren't vaccinated
and and i just you know i wanted i was
ready to get the vaccine i've always
felt it was
safe and effective i applaud what
president trump did with operation warp
speed to bring
multiple vaccines to the market in the
quickest time ever
but it's not because they cut corners
they tested it on thousands of people
before ultimately you got that fda
conditional use approval so
it's safe and effective i took it and i
wanted to show the picture to
to just encourage people you know
government shouldn't be mandating it or
trying to shame people we should be
getting the facts out there and
encouraging people
uh to take it and if they have
hesitation talk to your doctor
because ultimately it should be a
decision between you and your doctor but
with the understanding that it is a safe
and effective and fda approved drug
and fda is still the gold standard for
the world
other states other countries marvel at
our process
but it's out there available for
everybody who wants it and your team
pfizer as am i back in april so and you
feel good right right i
i feel great felt great excellent
question for you about what's happening
in the senate lindsey graham
says there's a power grab that he has
yet to see before in his time in
congress
here he is with laura last night watch
this is a power grab
the three and a half trillion dollar
democratic infrastructure package has
got not a damn thing to do with
infrastructure
they're wanting to put amnesty in the
infrastructure bill
okay so this is what we think is
interesting bipartisan spending but i
don't know if it's going to happen or
not you got
579 billion in new spending 300 billion
in transportation there's a thought that
this thing is falling apart right now
and if it does
dems go alone and they may have a
package in excess of four
trillion dollars do you believe that
passes
in america in the year 2021 given the
state of things now
well bill first of all for for the good
of our country i hope it doesn't pass
because
this drunken spending bit democrats have
been on for the last six months
is having a real effect on inflation
it's increasing the cost of everything
we buy
because they're spending money like
crazy they're paying people not to work
it's all borrowed money
from our kids and it's raising costs uh
whether you go to the grocery store at
the
gasoline at the pump it's increasing
inflation and i think people across the
country get that
but they don't want to do this for
infrastructure there was a bipartisan
deal
that joe biden himself walked away from
he gave his word to republican and
democrat senators
that he was going to support a
bipartisan infrastructure deal and then
within an hour pelosi and schumer
threatened him
and he and he folded like a cheap suit
and said okay well we'll go down the tax
hike road
their bill on reconciliation is nothing
but
a massive multi-trillion dollar spending
bill and tax hike bill
they want to raise taxes in a way that
would move more middle class jobs
overseas that's horrible policy but
right now the good news is they don't
have the votes
and i don't think they have a plan to
get the votes because none of our
members support
that tax hike green new deal amnesty
spending plan
but some of their own members on the
democrat side in the house and senate
don't support it right now either and so
speaker pelosi and chuck schumer are
scrambling
what they should be doing is is letting
joe biden follow through on the word he
gave during the campaign and that's
working with
people on both sides of the aisle he's
failed in that mission
to do it but right now that's one of the
reasons they don't have the most he's
got a chance now
yeah i hate to cut you off there i'm out
of time here but where there's two
trillion
or three or four trillion you name the
number uh
you don't know what's in it and byron
donald's from florida 30 minutes ago
said
and neither do they referring to
senators yeah on the other side
steve scalise thank you for your time we
will speak again